KAI HALEY: Well, thank
you all for joining.
Thank you so much for coming
here today to speak with us
with Barry O'Reilly.
He is one of the authors
of "Lean Enterprise"
and has graciously agreed to
come talk to the Sprint Master
Academy about his ExecCamp,
which I'm very excited to hear
about, and the
work that he's been
doing to help organizations
transform and adopt change.
Barry's going to start
with a quick presentation
about his work and his process.
And then, We'll have a
fireside chat, some questions,
and we do have Adore
for those of you
who want to add questions
in there who are not here
in person.
I'll hand it over to Barry.
Thank you so much.
BARRY O'REILLY: Thank you.
ExecCamp, thank you very much.
Every CEO briefing ever,
what do you think happens?
People come along.
They listen to the
executive tell them
what they're going to do.
What do the execs tell
them is going to happen?
AUDIENCE: Big change.
BARRY O'REILLY:
Big change, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Everything's
going to be better.
BARRY O'REILLY: Everything's
That's right.
The thing I hear every single
time is, we need to transform.
We need to transform
our business.
We need to change the way
that we're doing things.
We need to innovate more.
Now, when they say "we,"
who are they talking about?
Are they talking
about you or them?
AUDIENCE: You.
BARRY O'REILLY: Exactly.
They're talking about you.
We need to transform means them
saying, you need to transform.
I'm just keep going to
keep doing the same things
that I've always done.
Now 87%, that's the amount
of Fortune S&P 500 companies
that have disappeared
since the last 20 years.
Huge amount of churn in the
most highest performing,
highest grossing
companies on the planet.
And unfortunately,
still today, the people
who are leading these companies
are advocating that they all
need to transform.
But they're not
transforming themselves.
The way that half of
the S&P 500 plan to grow
is by cost reduction activities.
Only 32% of them plan to grow
by new products and services.
What I have been
experiencing when
we were writing
"Lean Enterprise"
and talking to a lot of
these large organizations
about what they were struggling
with, how to drive innovation
in their entire
enterprise, we started
to understand that the
problem isn't actually
the people in the company.
They want to change.
They want to try new things.
But unfortunately,
the leadership,
the people who are
running the company,
are struggling to
actually understand
how to drive that change
themselves and transform
themselves.
I decided it was time
to create a new model,
a new model for driving
change in large enterprises.
And this is why we
invented ExecCamp.
What I do in ExecCamp is
I get senior executives
from large, multibillion
dollar organizations
to leave their company
for four to eight weeks
with the goal of launching
new businesses to disrupt
their existing organizations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
That's right.
CEOs, CFOs, heads of technology
leaving their existing company
for almost two months to try and
launch new companies to blow up
their existing business.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BARRY O'REILLY: Sound like fun?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BARRY O'REILLY:
Does it sound crazy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BARRY O'REILLY: Great.
It is.
Because it's awesome.
Because what we're
trying to create
is an environment where
executives can actually
get out of their comfort zone.
They actually
understand what it's
like to get back at the
front line of innovation,
to understand the challenges
about what's going out there.
I also want them
to learn by doing.
They've read every management
book under the sun.
They look at models like
Build-Measure-Learn and say,
we're doing that.
But it's very different to
actually go through a learning
cycle than to look at it on
paper and how easy it is to do.
I get them back to understand
how to learn by doing,
by actually experiencing
innovation at the front line.
They also then, at the
end of the eight weeks,
go back to the organization
as coaches for other people,
so they can start to
understand the challenges
that their people are
facing on the front line
and coach them how
to do experimentation
and learning better.
Now, they also get to
test lots of ideas.
In order to come up
with a good idea,
you have to have lots of ideas,
generate optionality and test
all those options to find
out which is the best signal
and invest in it more.
But the challenge
in large corporates
is, because of the
funding cycles involved
in getting initiatives to start,
they can potentially only make
one or two bets a year.
And they're massive bets.
They take multi-year to deliver.
They always get half
of what they want.
They're always twice
as long as they
thought they'd be and
cost four times the amount
that they planned.
But that's a feedback cycle
in a large organization,
potentially one to
two years before you
get feedback on your idea.
What I'm showing them is
how they can get feedback
in a minute, in a
second, how they
can test those options
to understand what works,
what doesn't, kill
things early, invest
and double down on what works.
And then finally,
the ultimate benefit
is when they leave their
company for these eight weeks,
it gives the
safe-to-fail experiment
for the next
generation of leaders
to take the role of
the CEO, of the CTO,
for a short period of time and
get experience, understanding,
what it's like to have that role
in a multimillion, 10, 100,000
person, type company for
a short period of time
and learn what it's
like to do that.
Anybody want to do it?
Sound like fun?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Let's do it.
BARRY O'REILLY: Let's do it.
Normally, at this
stage, it goes two ways.
When I sit down with
the executive team,
there either go, that's amazing.
We're going to do it.
Or they go, you're crazy.
Get the hell out of here.
And I'm lucky to say I get
kicked out of plenty of rooms.
But by, I think, the people who
are the visionary leaders, who
understand that the nature
of the environment we're in
is about complexity,
it's about change,
and you need to embrace both and
find ways to experiment, to do
things radically different to
drive your business forward,
they're the people
who ask me to stay.
And they're the
kind of people who
are going to lead
their organizations
through these transformations.
Because it's difficult. There's
a high amount of uncertainty.
And this is why
experimentation is so key.
But before you do
all these things,
these are why things
like techniques
that I use like Design
Thinking, like Lean Startup,
and applying them to the
enterprise principles
are so important.
Getting people,
cross-functional groups,
in a room to work together
to solve big problems.
And I love this
diagram that was given
to me by a guy
called Jeff Patton,
and also shared with me
by another guy called
Luke Barrett.
And I love this idea
of the three characters
are like, yeah, we all agree.
But someone's thinking
about a circle.
Someone's thinking
about a square.
Someone's thinking about
a different type of shape.
But we all agree.
We think we agree.
And then we say, well,
let's visualize that.
Let's externalize our thoughts
and put them up on a wall.
And then, suddenly,
I know that Kai's
thinking about a triangle.
I'm thinking about a circle.
That's probably
not the same thing.
And you can see the genesis
here of what Design Thinking is
about, Lean about, visualizing
what you are thinking about,
and using models to
externalize our thoughts,
debate what we're trying to
solve, come to a consensus,
and execute and test
that experiment.
And all the methods I use
through these processes
are embracing those
principles of experimentation,
of visualization, and
testing and learning.
Now, just before anyone
thinks I'm too crazy,
there's one other thing
I always have to show.
People are like, this is great.
This is really interesting.
But how does it work?
And it's OK.
Because I've got a
diagram that wiggles
but goes up and to the right.
So managers feel safe.
But really what I do, innovation
needs to be structured.
You need to deliberately
practice experimentation.
Having an outline for
methods that we'll go through
is really important
so people understand
how they're going
to contribute, what
is expected of them
at different stages,
and what we're going
to actually achieve.
This is the framework we use.
We talk about Prepare.
And it says, Plan, Educate,
and Ready the Team.
Senior executives in
large, multibillion dollar
organizations have no time.
No spare time.
They're booked up for
three months in advance.
What I start to do is create
a lightweight intervention
program with them.
In the lead-up to
taking the ExecCamp,
I'll spend one hour
a week with them
where I'll introduce
them to certain models
that we might use, maybe
personas, maybe business model
canvases, maybe value
proposition canvases.
They start to understand
some of the tools
that they're going to be
using, everything from simply
how to peel a Post-it
and why we use Sharpies
right through to very complex
ways of describing business
models that they can test.
I also do psychoanalogy
work with them,
helping them understand that
Barry's an abstract thinker,
doesn't really enjoy
detail, would be good for
vision, terrible for execution.
But then Kai is probably
amazing at detail-oriented
and execution.
You have to build context
about these teams.
Because when they come together
for a short period of time,
you don't have time to sit
around and wait for everybody
to understand and work together.
You're trying to
reduce the uncertainty
of having a high performance
team from day one.
Build models that
people can share
context about one another,
both their biases,
their preferences, and
their capabilities.
We can understand quickly have
we the right mix of a team?
Can we create
psychological safety?
Again, something that's
come from the Aristotle
Project here at Google.
And then, can you
give them the tools
that they're going to need
to help them be successful?
Prime them.
The Immerse stage, then,
is getting them out
of their comfort zone.
Most executives can only
see what's in front of them.
Every idea that
they have or issue
that they have in
the company, they've
got a point solution to fix it.
When you ask them to
think bigger, all they do
is come up with
the idea that they
think is going to
fix the business,
but they couldn't get it
funded for five years.
It's very hard to stick
people in a room for two days
and tell them,
change the business,
and then sit in this
room for three days
and we'll change the business.
Innovation doesn't
necessarily happen in rooms.
It happens where the
work's happening,
where people see problems.
You need to help open their mind
to what's happening externally,
go and see what other
technology companies are doing,
startups are doing, interesting
competitors are doing.
But then, also understand the
assets that your business has,
the capabilities yours has,
and how you can leverage them.
Bring the best of both worlds.
Large corporates are
large because they
have a business model and
capabilities that work well.
If you can leverage those in
a new and interesting way,
either with partnerships or
to open innovation frameworks,
you can create something
even more better.
Ideate, then, is basically
ways that we generate
tons and tons of ideas.
We use those inputs to help
us understand lots of options.
And then testing everything.
The thing we always
optimize for is
testing as many
ideas as possible,
constantly generating
new inputs,
but then getting the
executives to go and talk
to the customers
about these ideas
that they've mapped out
themselves, or built
simple prototypes for.
And get feedback to
understand if it works or not.
Now, this is the most
uncomfortable thing
for executives that
they could ever do.
One of my favorite stories
from doing this is I
had the CTO of one of
the largest airline
companies on the planet.
And he had a great
idea that he was
like, we just found this idea.
We're going to
save the business.
It's going to be amazing.
And I was like, brilliant.
OK.
We'll just sketch it out.
Let's make a prototype.
Let's go talk to
customers about it.
Sat down, showed the
idea to a customer.
What do you think happened?
AUDIENCE: Customer
didn't understand it?
BARRY O'REILLY: The customer
didn't understand it.
What do you think the reaction
of this person, the CTO, was?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
how they do it.
BARRY O'REILLY: How could the
customer not understand it?
Yes.
Dumb customer.
Silly customer.
Bring me the next one.
So we brought another customer.
And we sat the customer down.
And the executive again showed
the idea to the silly customer.
What do you think
happened again?
Same thing happened again.
Bring me another customer.
They're just--
But eventually, the
message got through
that they started to understand
that the people that they were
designing for didn't
understand what they
were trying to communicate.
And they could
start to understand
that the value of testing
that hypothesis, that idea,
that prototype,
with the customer
was the best mechanism that they
would have for getting feedback
to make a better
decision or improve it.
And I'm delighted to say
that that person is probably
one of the most transformative
characters as a result
of this mechanism that
they changed everything
that the way they worked.
They saw everything
as an experiment
from new products
and the processes
they designed, the strategy
that they've designed.
And this is really
important for when
you're trying to help people
go through and understand
and start to learn.
You have to create
an environment where
they test their mental model of
the world and make a discovery.
Learn something new about it.
And that's what prototyping
and experimentation is about.
How can I put my idea
out there specifically
with the people
it's designed for
and get feedback to see
does it work or not?
I'm testing my
assumptions of the world.
And by using that
mechanism, I've
discovered that that's the best
way to drive change in people.
It's very difficult
for you to tell me
why Design Thinking is
the way I should work.
Create an experiment where
I get to use Design Thinking
and see the benefits
of it rather than
just listen to your opinion.
Help me experience
it so then I change
my mental model of the world.
Really important.
And then finally, with the
Impact and Scale pieces,
when you've tested
all these great ideas,
the best people to bring
them back into the company
and try and drive them forward
are the executives themselves.
They understand bureaucracy.
They understand how
to drive initiative
through the organization using
the culture and the practice
and the principles
that they've used
in ExecCamp to keep propagating
and scaling that idea out.
And then, my goal is always
to try and teach people
how to run these themselves.
I talk about see one,
do one, teach one.
The first time the executives
come to an ExecCamp,
they're seeing.
It's the first time
that they do it.
What I try to encourage
them next time
is that they coach other people
to see it for the first time.
And they start to do,
or lead, one themselves.
Finally then that they start
to teach it to other people
in the organization,
which creates the ability
to scale it.
I've been doing this
for nearly a year now.
It's been pretty amazing.
I've had lots of
great experiences.
I've run it for one of the
largest airlines in the world.
I've done it for one
of the largest cargo
companies in the world.
I was in JFK airport
last week actually
helping them transform the
way that they actually design
and build airports.
This has been one the most
interesting and intriguing
things I've ever done.
And the people who have
been through this process,
it's fundamentally changing the
way that they see the world.
It's transformative
for them in many ways.
What I'm going to share
today, and I hope we can,
through lots of
questions and debate
about what we've
been doing, is just
talk about how do you drive
large scale transformation
in multibillion
dollar organizations
and get successful results
using the methods like Design
Thinking, Lean Startup,
and experimentation
to create high
performance at scale,
test lots of great
ideas, but have
a cultural impact
in organizations
that they constantly
embrace these principles
and constantly transform.
KAI HALEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much, Barry.
BARRY O'REILLY: Yup.
KAI HALEY: That was really
fascinating to hear about.
One of the goals of the
Sprint Master Academy
is to do similar work and
train a large number of Sprint
Masters to create
opportunities for innovation
and transformation
across Google.
We have a lot of adoption of
our Design Sprint Methodology
already.
But Sprint Masters
are still tasked
with convincing
stakeholders and leadership
to buy into the Sprint
process and to run sprints.
Do you have any advice for
this group of Sprint Masters,
in terms of
persuading leadership
to adopt innovation
methods and to make
room and space for innovation?
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah.
I think there's a few parts
to unpick in the question.
I think convincing
executives that they
need to do innovation is
not a hard sell these days.
Right?
They see companies that
existed four or five
years ago just disappearing.
They are in their
organization struggling
to see how can we
bring new ideas to life
and how do we do that?
I think they understand
that they need to do it.
The big challenge is they
don't know how to do it.
Because a lot of
large corporates
have become massively
large because they
have maybe one business
model, or one product
that make them
massively successful.
And their whole business has
just been tuning that one idea,
extract a [INAUDIBLE] from it.
And then, when you
ask them to say well,
keep optimizing what
you've got, but now you've
got to find a new thing.
They're like, well, this isn't
a natural competency, or scale,
or reflex that we
have as a business.
They know they need to do it.
But they don't
know how to do it.
I think this is where things
like the Sprint Design
process advocated by Google
and lots of companies
using Design Thinking
methodologies
is really, really important.
Because very quickly,
in lightweight ways,
you can help and
show executives ways
that they can make discoveries.
They are interested about
discovering new information
about their business, their
product, customers have to say.
What I would always
encourage you to do
is rather than keep trying
to sell the process of we've
got this amazing
process, try and create
a very simple and small
experience for them
where they get to see the
benefit of using that process.
You almost don't want to
tell them what you're doing.
You want to sort of say to them,
OK, what's one of the problems
that you're really struggling
with at the moment?
All right.
How could we quickly
map that problem out?
We could use a canvas.
Or we could describe
it in a journey.
OK.
Where's the most
uncertainty in this process?
Where are we having difficulty,
challenge, friction,
whatever it might be?
How could we learn
something that would help
us reduce that uncertainty?
What little test could
we go and run and do?
Maybe we need to go and talk to
a customer about this process
we're trying to change.
Make them go and do that.
And then, it's almost like
in the reflecting periods,
you're like, well, we've just
done some Design Thinking
activities there.
Because they'll
go and experience
this idea of just
trying something new,
working in a different way.
I think we're all confident
to say that anytime
you talk to a customer,
any time you test an idea,
you always learn something.
Once you can create
that simple experience,
it's a small experiment.
They can carve out a short
bit of their time to do it,
but they'll learn the benefits.
They'll experience it, and
learn something, and go,
this is great.
How can I do more?
And it's selling itself
then at that stage.
Then you can start to unpack
it and say, well, this
is the methods
that we use to help
explore uncertainty
and understand
ambiguity and so forth.
But they've experienced it.
So they've something to talk to.
The hard part is when you're
just constantly saying,
look at this process we do.
Look at this.
Here, look at this great
diagram of our process.
Isn't it so much fun?
It looks awesome.
Everybody does this.
When you're a leader
in an organization,
everybody's trying to sell
you on their thing, why
their thing is awesome, and if
you just invested in our thing,
you would be awesome too.
I think the trick is just
creating experiences for people
just like you do when
you design things.
Because experience
is what helps people
challenge their mental
model and assumptions
and builds context of something.
That's what I always
try to do when I start.
KAI HALEY: Interesting.
Yeah.
We find that at Google, we like
to do these small experiments
to show impact.
But being able to
demonstrate that impact,
speak about that impact
in a language that's
really valuable to
leadership is something
that we're learning
and developing.
In terms of stakeholder
participation,
we often struggle to get
stakeholders to actually
participate in this process.
And we find that
it can be valuable,
but actually getting people
to dedicate the time, have you
found, is there
any particular way
of talking about the process
that helps to help show
how valuable that time will be?
BARRY O'REILLY: That's a perfect
[INAUDIBLE] question again.
I was showing a little
bit of the high level
process of what we use when
we're working in ExecCamp.
One of the most important
things that came out
of the whole Agile movement was
when they had Agile ceremonies,
you're very explicit about
the purpose of that ceremony.
What type of conversation
is going to happen there?
What input or feedback you
expect to happen, and how
that will inform you
to take your next step.
Just to simplify, an
Agile team standup,
that's a chance for them to
solve ambiguity from the day
before.
Here's a problem we had.
I might need your help.
Can you spare four hours to
work with me this afternoon,
or tomorrow, or
whatever, on that?
People would share
context and move on.
It happens every day.
Great.
Maybe at the end of
iteration as an Agile team,
they'd bring all the work that
they've learned for the month,
or whatever, the week,
or whatever it was.
And then, they'd share
that to another audience
and say, give us
feedback on that.
But all those ceremonies, it
is very clear about what's
going to happen, who
needs to be there,
what decisions are
going to be made,
and how you're going
to input to that.
Now executives, especially
of multimillion dollar
organizations, don't
have a lot of time.
Their time is very precious.
It's very valuable.
And a lot of the
time, you've got
to design a working
system to fit in
with what the type of schedule
they're going to have.
Like with ExecCamp, it
takes us in the region
between three to six months
to get time in their diary
to actually clear
a couple of weeks
that they can go and do this.
And some of the executives,
what works really well
for them is we do two
hours in the morning,
two hours in the afternoon.
Right?
10:00 to 12:00, 2:00 to 4:00.
In those sessions,
it's very explicit
what we're going to be doing.
It's very deliberate
about the practices
that we're going to make
and use, the decisions we
want to make.
They're going into
those sessions
primed because you have to
make the most of every second.
You do that for
four or five days.
And they know that they'll
do it for four or five days
and then they'll
put it all together
and showcase it at the end of
the day to other stakeholders.
It's very, very disciplined.
And it's structured.
And it's clear to them.
Roles and responsibilities
are very clear.
You have to be very conscious
about explaining that
to senior leadership.
Because their time is, so
many people competing for it,
you've got to show
why it's important,
what they're going
to get out of it,
and how to leverage it
as quickly as possible.
KAI HALEY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Barry, you use
the term "they" a lot.
Is it one-on-one for them?
KAI HALEY: Just
use the microphone
so we can be sure to hear it.
AUDIENCE: You use the
term "they" a lot.
Is it mainly
one-on-one training?
Or is it actually
a group activity?
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah.
It's a group.
Generally, we try to
create a cross-functional--
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the question, briefly?
BARRY O'REILLY: Oh, sorry.
OK.
The question was
during ExecCamp,
is it just one-on-one training?
Or something else?
And the answer is,
it's something else.
Thank you for correcting me.
What I try to do is create
a cross-functional group
from across the entire business.
I don't necessarily
just want technology.
It's the CFO, chief financial
officer, the head of sales,
the head of marketing,
the head of HR.
And I get them to form
a cross-functional team.
Because you need
to fight the silos
that naturally exist
in large corporates.
Putting them in
rooms with designers,
with developers, and
so forth, so people
who can rapidly take
the ideas that they have
and turn them into
substance to be tested.
Might be a prototype,
might be a wireframe,
might be working software,
depending on the investment
you want to make.
So this group live, act,
and breathe together
for the entire duration
of the program.
And that, in itself, is a great
learning experience for them.
Because they don't actually get
to work together very often.
And you're also deciding
trade-offs and sharing
a lot of contents very quickly.
Because someone, say, in
the technology department
might have a really
great idea that's
going to change the business.
But your CFO can very quickly
identify, potentially,
the total cost of bringing
that thing to life
that might not necessarily be
the avenue you want to go down.
I saw that a few times when we
did some of the Exec campuses,
very quickly what you
find is technologists
just want to throw technology
to solve the problem.
We're trying to build
another food delivery app.
Oh, yeah, we'll just
machine learn it.
What the hell?
Yeah, machine learning
will fix that.
They just throw these
arbitrary comments out there.
But what you get in a
cross-functional team
is the marketing
person will say, well,
how will our
customers understand
what this idea is about?
The finance person will
be like, all right, well,
what would be our potential
revenue return from this?
It's just a different
set of questions
that start to emerge rather
than, hey, I've got a problem.
This technology will solve it.
Let's go build it.
And that's one of the
benefits of having
a cross-functional group.
Vice versa, you'll have a lot
of traditional, less exciting,
design-creative people
like finance coming up
with some really quite
intriguing ideas.
And that's what you're
really trying to create.
KAI HALEY: Great.
One of the other channels that
a lot of Sprint Masters have
is supporting the work
after the initial ideation
process, or that
initial Design Sprint,
and figuring out,
planning the paths
to launch for their products.
Is there any advice you can
give on continual support
for execution post that
initial Design Thinking work?
BARRY O'REILLY: Yes.
The very first ExecCamp we
ran, we did eight weeks.
We came up with four
transformation ideas.
They were going to
change the business.
It was brilliant.
And then, we brought them
back into the company
and they all died.
They died, literally,
within two weeks--
KAI HALEY: Wow.
BARRY O'REILLY: --which was
pretty impressive, I thought.
That was a great
learning for us.
Because we thought by having
the energy, the enthusiasm,
we had the leadership, they were
going to bring these ideas back
to the company.
And what they stopped doing
was living and breathing
and working in
the same practices
that I had used before,
sitting down every week
and setting a goal for what
we're going to try and learn
this week, constantly
reevaluating the larger
vision and the steps that we
were going to do to achieve
that vision, not just
in the next week,
but the next week, the next
month, the next three months.
That all just stopped.
They just went back to
their business as usual,
which was, oh, we've
got these great ideas.
Now, we'll just put them into
our usual development process
where they can go to die
slowly and painfully.
That was one of
the great learnings
for us is that you actually
have to, again, design
that type of governance
process into what
happens when you come back into
the company with these ideas.
Because people who are working
on the typical BAU business,
they'll often go, oh, you're
just off dreaming up new stuff.
I've got 100 other
things I need to do.
Why should I pick up
the thing that you're
going to come back and work on?
I think having a very
clear governance structure
about, right, the ideas have
come back, we've tested them,
this is what we've
learned, our next learning
goal for the next week is x.
In a month, we need
to be looking at y.
Our bigger vision
beyond that is--
And then, keep using
the iterative approach
of having sessions organized
with your stakeholders
where you are constantly
showcasing what you're learning
from the experiments that you've
agreed to run for that week,
for that month,
whatever they might be.
And keep the heartbeat going.
If you don't design
that into the process,
and people don't sign
up to that while they
are part of the Design
Sprint process, you're dead.
Just don't even waste your time
on Day one after the sprint.
You need to have owners.
You need to have actions.
You need to have a plan.
And build that
plan aim get people
to commit to it because
if you don't, you've
just wasted a sprint.
AUDIENCE: Is it OK,
a follow-up question?
KAI HALEY: Yes, yes.
BARRY O'REILLY: Keep asking.
Please.
It's for the room, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have
experienced that myself.
Great ideas die a
very slow death.
Has there ever been talked about
during those sessions that you
had with those executives in
changing the incentive in model
to the reward
system that exists?
A lot of times,
tech organizations
arrive on launch, literally
like notches in the belt.
But has that changed?
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah.
That's a great question.
Do I repeat that again?
AUDIENCE: Please.
BARRY O'REILLY: The question
was although when you come back
with these great ideas, is
there a conflict, basically,
with the existing
performance management
KPIs of an operating business
to not invest in these ideas?
And the simple answer
is yes there is.
And it has a bias
on the behaviors
that it will drive in people.
And it will also have a bias
on them, individuals, right?
They're told certain
metrics that they
have to hit all the time.
Now, the problem here is
most large organizations
have used the same
standard set of KPIs
used to run their business,
most of them from inception.
A lot of the classic
KPIs that are associated
with operating businesses--
And I just want to make a
distinction between what
a business model
or product that's
existed for a period
of time and they
have lots of data
to understand how
it performs versus an
experimental idea which
where it's a new idea.
You've very little data
about the performance.
It's no history.
They're totally
different things.
Yet, the prevailing methodology
for managing the performance
of any initiative is
all based on products
that existed for a long time.
Classic examples are revenue
or return on investment.
We've invested 5 million in
this product for 10 years.
And we know that we're going to
make a million dollars a year
as a result of that.
They have the data to
inform that decision.
When you're working in a highly
uncertain and experimental type
environment, you have no data.
You have to invest to find out.
That's the whole point
of running experiments
and why you want to run
small, cheap, fast experiments
is you want tight feedback
loops to generate data to help
you make a better decision.
When you come up
with a new product,
the reason you want to
talk to 10 customers
and define how
many customers have
to like the idea for
you before you progress
it, before you run the
experiment, is you're
trying to create a test.
You're trying to create a
loose set of KPIs to say,
seven out of 10 customers
don't like this idea.
We're going to say we're going
to make a different decision.
We're going to kill it.
That's how you're using
your loose set of KPIs
to make decisions.
And that's called
Innovation Accounting.
And it was popularized in
the "Lean Startup" book
by Eric Ries.
But when you start to
actually then bring
executives and finance
people into this world,
you have to show
them that there is
a method to what you're doing.
Just saying that I'm going
to disappear off and innovate
and not hold myself accountable
to any sort of decision
making framework
is not acceptable.
But when you sit down and
explain to them to say, look,
we don't, it's highly uncertain.
But we're going to test
this idea with 10 customers.
And if seven of them like it,
we're going to keep going.
Does that sound like
a good test to you?
They will engage
straight away and they'll
understand that you're
not just going crazy here.
You're very deliberate.
You have a clear
method and a way
to make decisions in conditions
of extreme uncertainty.
That's what innovation is about.
And if you can build
those skills into the way
that you work,
that's where you can
start to bring them on their
transformational experience
to understand why you're doing
things, why you can't talk
about ROI on an idea that you've
only tested with one person.
That's the trick.
KAI HALEY: Yes.
Come here.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks.
So one of the things Google
Design Sprint Methodology
forces us to do is you
have to go into the sprint
with a very clear problem
you want to solve.
It sounds like from
what you're saying
the ExecCamp is a little
different in the sense
that you walk in with
[INAUDIBLE] blank slate.
You come up with either
completely brand new solutions,
transformative
solutions, [INAUDIBLE]
what you already had.
Your [INAUDIBLE].
How do you guide or
constrain the process?
And do you even try to do that?
Or is it just like come up
with whatever you come up
with, whether it's crazy, blue
sky, 10 years down the line,
or short term, it
doesn't matter?
BARRY O'REILLY: Brilliant.
Just to repeat the question,
typically in a Design Sprint
within Google, we have
a specific challenge
or question that we're
trying to answer.
In ExecCamp, it sounds like
you've more of a blank canvas.
How do we manage the idea that
people just, doesn't everyone
tries to create
Uber for the next x,
or whatever it might be?
How do we constrain it a bit?
I think the answer is
for any design to happen,
you need constraints.
You have to set some
sort of constraint
around a problem
space or a boundary.
Now, because we're
working typically
at the executive level, they're
thinking of moonshot equivalent
ideas.
That's what you're trying
to encourage them to do.
But the way I
constrain them is we
use a technique called
Transformational Targets.
It's a small, little
workshop that I
run where we put basically
a radar on the wall.
And we say to
them, what would be
transformative
for your business?
Describe something that would
radically change the way
your business operates.
Now, just to give an
example, for instance,
in the cargo business,
and this is great stuff
that I've been
learning since I've
been working with
these companies,
there's paper everywhere.
Paper for paper for
paper for paper.
It's unbelievable.
The next time you're
getting on a plane,
you see these cargo bays
going in underneath the plane,
everything on that has
to have a piece of paper
to describe what it is, what
it's about, who's it going to.
It's all handwritten.
It's passed.
When you get on the plane, the
last thing to get on a plane
is a huge satchel of paper which
describes all the things that
are on the plane.
They have massive issues
like double-typing,
or can't read handwriting.
This is why all your bags
disappear most of the time.
In that industry, when we
did the exercise with them,
we were like, what
would be transformative
for your business?
And they were like, no paper.
0% paper.
So we were like, brilliant.
OK.
That sort of gives
us a constraint.
And they came up with other
things like financial measures,
or people development,
and so quite a big radar,
prioritized them,
and then coming up
with a shortlist of maybe four.
I'd like to say
between three and five
that are
transformational targets.
They have to be smart goals.
So they have to
say like 0% paper.
Or plus 20% NPS
score in two years.
They have to be
measurable and scientific.
And then, what we
do is when we start
to generate all these ideas, the
way we challenge them and say,
will Uber for airlines
get rid of paper?
And it's that sort of question
to challenge and constrain
it a little bit.
And then, it gives us
something to test against.
Again, we're creating this
governance framework all
the time of well, in order for
an idea to be worth challenging
and moving forward,
it has to fit
within these transformational
targets we've set ourselves.
And that again, gives us
another feedback mechanism
to say, well, how can we make
this idea more transformative?
And so on.
That's the technique we use.
But yes, definitely, when you're
in the Design Sprint world,
there's probably more of an
optimization of an existing
problem.
But we get to that stage too.
You get there through iteration.
So over time, the
challenge becomes clearer.
But at the inception
of the workshops,
they're still quite
very broad ideas.
There's lots of fuzziness
around the outside.
But we reduce that through
the testing cycles.
And the way we test
is generally they
have to do two customer
interviews a week.
So the execs have to sit
down with their ideas
and showcase them to customers
feedback twice a week.
We generally invite
in someone from a VC
or a business
thought leader where
they have to pitch to
someone external in the room.
So they keep challenging
their own thinking about how
the business stands up.
And then, at the end
of every two weeks,
they've got to pitch back to the
CEO of the entire organization
and say, this is
what we've learned.
This is what we're
going to do next.
Do you want to keep
investing in this?
So we even apply experimentation
to the process itself.
Because if they invest in two
or three weeks' worth of work,
and they're like, this
isn't working for us.
Cool.
Let's kill it.
We've just been lucky
enough, I don't know,
maybe, I'd like to think
that we're actually
working in a good way.
But everyone who's got to
that stage has kept investing,
wants to keep going.
But again, it's a
different person
to challenge your thinking.
You've always got to
keep bringing people in
to challenge the
bias in the room.
Eventually, we'll all think
something's a great idea.
So we show it to a customer to
get a different perspective.
Eventually we'll, again, think
everything's a great idea.
We'll show it to
someone who's a VC,
give us a different
type of feedback.
That's what we try
to propagate and live
a lot of the principles
that we advocate while we're
running these things.
And that's what makes
it so invigorating
because no two
have been the same.
We've got a high level
deliberate method,
but the adaptability comes on
what we learn with each client
when we do it.
And we just pivot
the whole process
to match what we're learning
as a team, which again, is very
exciting, but very challenging.
Because every day
you got to come up
with a new set of
activities to run.
A most execs, when you go, we're
going to do this for the day,
they're like, no we're not.
KAI HALEY: Well, that sounds
very, very challenging.
Fascinating.
We have a few more minutes.
Are there any other questions?
Yes.
Go ahead.
I wanted to open it up to
questions across the board.
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah.
Of course, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I found that people
tend to struggle with the word
"design."
They'll hear Design
Sprint and Design Thinking
and they're like, well,
OK, that's a designer.
They just draw a few
pictures all day.
What do they know about
businesses or launching
products?
I'm wondering if you use the
word "design" thinking Design
Sprint [INAUDIBLE] what you do.
And if not, what do
you say [INAUDIBLE]?
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah, thank you.
It's funny.
The way I think of the
world now is that we're
all designers, actually.
The CEO is designing a company,
is designing a business.
And I talk to them very
much from that premise.
But to the second
part of your question,
I do try to stay away,
as much as possible,
from telling people that we're
going to do Design Thinking.
We're going to do Lean Startup.
We're going to do
Lean Enterprise.
I don't even tell people when
I work with them that we're
going to do Lean Enterprise.
What I talk to them
much more about
is what they're going to
learn as a result of trying
these new things, that they're
going to use techniques that
feel very uncomfortable to
start because they've never
done them before.
But again, I try to be very
clear about the expectations
of the goal of these methods
is to help you learn fast
what works, what
doesn't, and should we
do something different to
generate better information,
to make better decisions.
And when I talk to people
like that, especially
the leadership, they listen.
Because they want to
make better decisions.
They want to have better
data to make those decisions.
They want to learn
things about how
their business or
their company operates.
They're very keen to do that.
Because you have
to remember when
you are a leader in an
organization the information
you get is so sanitized.
I call it "watermelon
reporting."
It's like, the delivery
team down on the bottom,
they're working away and
something's not working.
So they put their
project report as red.
And they pass it up
to the next person.
And the person is like, well,
I don't want that to be red.
Someone might shout out at me.
So I'll just turn it to
amber and pass that on.
And then, the next
person is well,
I don't want to be shouted at.
I'll just turn that amber.
It's going to be OK.
They're going to make it.
I'll turn it to green.
And then, the people who
are leading the organization
have these reports
that are filled
with inconsistent
or incorrect data.
And then, that's the information
they use to make decisions
about how to run the business.
So when stuff
doesn't work or they
get the consequences
they don't expect,
they're making
decisions from bad data.
There's an ownership on us
to help them understand that.
And that's why I get them
to talk to customers.
Because it's raw data.
It's customer feedback.
It's as raw as it gets.
And they love it.
Because they're like,
I'm learning stuff.
Hey, that process I designed
for hiring, it sucks.
Yes.
We should change that.
Because they never
get that insight.
They're just told,
yeah, it's working.
There's a few problems,
but we're ironing it out.
They want to hear that
it sucks because they
want to make it better.
All those ideas about bringing
data to a conversation,
helping them learn new things,
helping them learn new skills,
I really more start
from there, and then
talk about the
benefits of what they
can do with that data
and those techniques.
And they can apply it to
all parts of their life.
And I used the word
experimentation quite a lot.
AUDIENCE: It seems like these
executives are going off
into this world for
nearly two months
and they're getting
a new way of working,
a new way of thinking that
is closer to their raw data.
But then they come back.
And you said you developed
these governance processes
to help bring this kind of
thinking back to their company.
But how does what
you do integrate more
with the culture
inside an organization
when those folks on the
ground might not be accepting?
The exec had to go through six
to eight weeks of ExecCamp,
what about the
folks on the ground?
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah, it's,
again, a fair question, right?
There's always inertia
when you take people out
of their day-to-day work
and you bring them off
somewhere else to do
something and bring them back.
And they're like, hey, we
went to the Joshua Tree.
And we've come back.
And now we see the world
in a different way.
Right?
This type of thing.
But I think it's
very powerful when
you have the leadership
of a company,
you have an experience
that is very
much like the day-to-day
operation for most
people in the company.
They get exposed to new ways
of thinking and working.
They get inspired by it.
One of the best
pieces that we've
had as a result of this
work is the CEO of one
of the largest banks in America.
We're working with
him and their team
to implement this type of stuff.
And we ran a retrospective.
And the biggest feedback
from the entire group
was, we thought
this stuff is easy.
It looks easy.
You plan, you do something,
you check, you act.
You build, you
measure, you learn.
You do an OODA loop, whatever.
It looks easy on paper.
But then, we actually have to
go through one of these learning
loops and realized
how difficult it was.
And then, he socialized that
with the entire organization.
He has an executive blog.
And he's like, I thought
this Agile stuff was easy.
It's actually really hard.
For the whole company,
that lifted everybody.
They're like, wow.
They actually
understand how tough it
is to do what I'm trying to do.
It's not simple.
And that, in itself,
builds empathy, which is,
again, a great tool as leaders
to understand the context
people are operating in.
That's what customer
development is about.
That's what Get Out Of
The Building is about.
That's what [INAUDIBLE]
Genba, or Go and See,
from when Toyota started off
all this stuff, is about.
And I think that's
probably the way
I try to challenge that
inertia and make the leadership
team aware of that,
that they need
to share their story because
that's what inspires people.
KAI HALEY: All right.
Thank you.
I think we're out of time.
We've reached the
end of our session.
Thank you so much, Barry.
BARRY O'REILLY: Yeah.
Thanks for all the questions.
It's really enjoyable to answer
them and challenge my thinking.
And it's a pleasure to be here
and share the story with you
all.
Thank you very much,
Kai, for inviting me
and everyone who's come along.
Thank you.
KAI HALEY: It was
wonderful to have you.
All right.
Thanks.